all right guys bang bang I've got Eric
and James here with me uh let's just
jump right into the news from yesterday
so BlackRock announced a Bitcoin trust
that will be publicly traded uh they
filed for it starts to be approved and
eventually start trading but one of the
big questions that everyone has is what
are the differences between blackrock's
fund and the grayscale Bitcoin trust
that is currently trading out in the
market
um okay I mean I'll take I'll give the
broad strokes and then James can give
the fine tuning the bottom line is this
the grayscale fund is essentially like
almost like a a private fund with
limited shares those shares trade over
the counter and so it's very easy for
those limited shares to have a price
that deviates from the underlying price
of Bitcoin because you cannot Arbitrage
the two
an ETF allows for continuous creation
redemptions thus if the ETF price starts
to deviate from the price of Bitcoin so
we'll are that because they can only
sell short the underlying and buy the
ETF or vice versa
that's the beauty of ETFs that creation
of redemption mechanism as I frequently
uh compared it to is the flux capacitor
uh to use back to the future of the ETF
it's the magic sauce gbtc does not have
that magic sauce it's essentially a
closed then fund and that's why
people do not like closed end funds or
something like gbtc because people are
okay if something goes down up or down
or whatever volatile they just want it
to track the price
and this is what this fund would do that
uh structured as it is so that's my
broad stroke on that I don't know if
James wants to dive a little deeper yeah
I mean the the real thing with the ETFs
is that you can change the supply to
meet demand which is basically what Eric
was saying so if you imagine like a
stock right it's the demand is what
changes it because for the most part
obviously there's stock based
competition other things but for the
most part demand is what drives the
price but what you really want in a fund
is you want the underlying values to be
driving the price of the fund and with
gbtc that just isn't happening and to be
clear that's not happening with gbtc but
grayscale is obviously they're suing the
SEC in court because they want to be
able to launch an ETF
um so from from the base level like
these trusts will be like this BlackRock
trust would be extremely similar to the
grayscale trust except they're going
after the ETF approval in the same way
that grayscale is except uh this trust
wouldn't start off as like Eric
mentioned they the way gbt started off
it was basically a private trust there
was a PPM a private placement memorandum
like you you were it was basically
private investing you needed to be an
accredited investor a qualified
purchaser which I'm sure you know all
about pomp but like basically you could
not anyone could just invest in it and
then they went through a bunch of
different processes to get it listed on
an exchange this is Blackrock is just
trying to go right from the gun and
launch an ETF and to be clear grayscale
has tried in the past and even before
they launched gptc we're interested in
launching an ETF and they knew they
couldn't so they settled on this process
of what they're currently doing with
their trust in gbtc
um because they couldn't get an ETF
approved from the SEC so both of you
have used interchangeably trust and ETF
and I think that one of the questions
that people have is uh grayscales
Bitcoin trust right the word is in there
is trying to convert to this kind of
spot Bitcoin ETF and that was blocked
their uh complaint is that will you
approve the Futures based ETF we think
that there should be a spot ETF and it
should be kind of evenly uh um the rule
should be evenly applied across the
market explain for people what the
difference for grayscale would be
between the trust structure and the ETF
and then when you think of what
BlackRock is doing are they trying to
become more like the trust or is it
actually something closer to that ETF
structure that grayscale wants to be
uh they're they're one of the same uh
grayscale would have to convert to the
same thing
um let me read a quote from my first
book here I'm gonna I'm just gonna do a
Shameless promotion on your podcast
problem the institutional ETF toolbox I
worked my ass off on this book so I I
and when if you want to not sell books
put the word institutional in the title
too so uh but it really could just be
the ETF toolbox it's written for retail
as well here's a quote from will Ryan
who was the uh who ran the world gold
Council GLD ETF this is one of my book
when I'm talking about Grant her trust
versus uh open-end funds when you want
to put Commodities into a fun-like
structure you can't use a 40x structure
which is an open-end fund structure you
have to adopt a different structure and
the one that works for Commodities is
this grantor trust it can hold a single
asset and doesn't need to be Diversified
in a way that a 40 act mutual fund has
to be so this is the gold Council guy
talking this is exactly the same
scenario uh that this one is going to be
structured as and just to give you some
perspective like 95 of ETF assets are in
funds they're 40ac funds only a small
Slicer in these other uh type of
structures that's why when we
communicate to people we try not to
bring this up too much because people
can start to get worried like an etn in
fact exchange traded note Grant her
trust there's Partnerships for
Commodities pools there's a couple just
weird things that people just got
creative in order to have like oil
futures or gold and ETF that could use
the 40 act so they found these other
ways but
to the person who's the end User it's
going to feel smell and and you're going
to experience exactly like an ETF that's
why we don't get too wonky with this
because it's unnecessary and in our
traffic light system GLD is a green
light we're okay with this the only it
gets one ding for the taxation because
it's taxed as a collectible because it's
actually gold whereas this Bitcoin ETF
we think might be green with zero
because I think the taxation would be
even more traditional and so again we've
GLD has been around for what 20 years at
this point
um it's fine it does the job we think
the same thing would happen with this
and that's why we're uh we're trying to
make sure everybody's clear on this
without getting in the weeds but I get
it the word trust everybody is attached
to gptc
um but it's like there are like the word
token remember how token got a bad name
after FTX but there are good tokens like
there's certain words that uh maybe get
tainted
but they actually are used in other
areas and it's a completely different
meaning or purpose so James maybe
um you could help people understand uh I
do agree that the investor experience is
very similar right in kind of these
things
um one of the questions that I had
people dming me last night about was
okay then why is grayscale trying to
convert from the trust to the ETF like
what are the advantages for grayscale
and
can now given what BlackRock is doing
can they stay in the trust structure and
just add in redemptions to kind of
compete here or what are some of the
implications of BlackRock entering the
market and this idea of grayscale trying
to convert yeah so I mean the the whole
thing is like what grayscale is really
trying to do the way to think about it
is the ETF is a wrapper so it goes
around all these other structures that
Eric was talking about like summer even
filed a c-corps like companies uh to
invest in MLPs there's a lot of
different ways that you can do this
um but I mean at the end of the day what
grayscale's trying to do is they need to
get around the regulation M
um they need right game exemption and
when you file for an ETF part of the
process of getting approval to launch an
ETF is you get Exempted from regulation
M so you can do continuous creations and
redemptions at the same time for a
vehicle that's trading on an exchange or
the over-the-counter so basically what
grayscale's trying to do is get reg M
exemption and launch an ETF and that's
the same thing that BlackRock is trying
to do now what does BlackRock mean for
grayscale it doesn't change anything
right now right there's nothing that's
going to happen currently with grayscale
because BlackRock filed for this now
what we think is Blackrock is I mean
they are the gorilla in the room for the
investment industry for ETFs they own
they're 33 of U.S ETF market right uh
vanguard's second at 30. so those two
are the the huge gorillas in the room
and when those two make moves like they
often don't miss right uh they're very
well connected they can read regulatory
tea leaves very well so obviously
they're launching for a reason right
they're filing sorry I shouldn't say
launching they're filed for this for a
very specific reason we think so we're
on our team I work with a few of us
covered the crypto World from multiple
different angles and one of us one of
our guys Elliot Stein is a litigation
analyst initially before the grayscale
hearing started he said grayscale's odds
of winning were 40 after the oral
arguments we heard he um grayscale's uh
chances of winning to 70 we think part
of the reason that BlackRock is now
filing for this product is because they
think grayscale is going to win their
lawsuit against the SEC so they think
it's only a matter of time so even if
even if let's say it's still only a 25
chance that this thing gets approved
right or 30 chance but BlackRock is
attributing getting it out first or very
very much in line when Drew BTC
conferred to whoever is able to launch
an ETF
that the money that they could
potentially get from being first or in
line with the first launches is probably
worth it even if the the odds of it
being approved are 30 we haven't like
really figured out what the odds are
Eric and I need to discuss it because
all this just happened yesterday but
like I'm not saying it's greater than 50
or 70 that BlackRock is going to get
this thing approved but the fact that
they're doing it means that they think
the odds of approval are enough and the
benefits of being in that in line first
are are worth it for them to to put this
filing out there are there downsides for
BlackRock putting in this filing and if
it gets denied or uh you know kind of
just sits there for a while sure maybe
there's some reputation stuff but are
there any other potential downsides
so um I would say one thing is this is
just irking the government um BlackRock
let's just be honest um some of the
bigger asset managers have people who
worked at the SEC who work there and
then they work there they go to the SEC
it's a little bit of a two-way street
so it would be weird I think if
BlackRock filed this
because what's going to happen now is
everybody and their mother who was in
line is going to rush back to get in
line so I I already called the over
under for files by the end of the day at
six we could have 12 15 by the end of
next week who knows if I'm an issuer I
wouldn't wait I would get right in there
so if BlackRock launches to this day I
want to be right with them
um because why wouldn't I so the SEC is
going to be really annoyed if BlackRock
does this and all these filings come in
they have to go through this whole
process again
it's just it's a bad it's a
administrative burden it's a bad look PR
wise so why would BlackRock do that if
they have so many connections and
intelligence about you know what regular
Regulators might be thinking they could
probably just call you know some of the
higher up circuit probably just call
somebody higher up there and just get
and feel them out that's my that's the
one question mark here there is a
downside for them and it's to really
irritate The Regulators because this is
going to spark a whole wave of filings
when you all look at uh things like fees
and this Redemption process
um are there areas where grayscale now
has to respond in terms of not
necessarily on the regulatory front but
in terms of the structure of the fund
I'm assuming BlackRock is not going to
come out with a two percent fee as
grayscale has maybe they will and
they're just like hey let's all just you
know stay at two percent and no one go
to go below that
um but but are there other implications
here to this filing if it is approved
where Grace go have to change some of
the structuring of the fund and the
experience for investors So based on the
filing no there are Futures ETFs that
exist that charge like 60 to 80 bips or
0.8 percent uh but grayscale is probably
not going to change anything until
there's an ETF approved right there
they're not going to have to worry about
anything changing or although I think I
personally think they should have
lowered the fee by now after they got so
much economies of scale but their
argument would be well we're fighting
the SEC with the money that we're
earning off the trust right
um so they're not going to have to to
change anything right now it's gonna
Everything Will Change when or if
um one of these things gets approved or
they win their lawsuit I just want to
say I did talk about the lawsuit but
there's like them winning the lawsuit
doesn't necessarily guarantee that the
SEC is going to approve this to launch
so it completely depends on the Court's
language right so if the court says you
have to approve these ETFs because you
approved the Futures ETFs or or what
have you then yeah there's going to be
spot Bitcoin ETFs but we don't think
that's very likely what's more likely is
that the court will basically say
um like you've kind of talked about in
the beginning you didn't treat like
situations alike you allowed Futures in
that spot so go back like you have to go
back to the drawing board and give a
different reason for denying the spot
Bitcoin ETFs or or approve it basically
so it'll leave it up to the SEC and the
SEC could theoretically then just go
back and give a denial or what they call
a disapproval letter uh for different
reasons so that's that's a distinct
possibility obviously my guess is that
BlackRock or some people at Barack Rock
probably don't think that's going to
happen and yeah the thing I would say is
like on the relationships
um genzler for the most part around the
industry even with some people around
the SEC is not well liked so he does not
have a good reputation
um even in the traditional Finance
community so that's another thing I
would say as far as like the
relationships go between Trad fire
companies and the SEC
let me just talk about the theme real
quick this is a very important point
that that one of the interesting facets
here is that uh coin
coinbase will be the custodian and
they're going to get a little slice of
that expense ratio and that's good for
them
but
they're they could lose business
um the whole crypto exchange World
should fear this because this ETF will
trade at one basis point a day or like
you could trade it for one basis point
right uh some are 40 50 some are even
highs 100 basis points to do a trade
the fee that the expense ratio in my
opinion if I had to guess BlackRock
would probably price this at 65. that's
my guess that would be four like
one-fourth to cost almost of uh
grayscale or one third of the cost
um that's compelling but then the other
ones are going to come in and very soon
there'll be one at 20. there's going to
be an instant fee War over this space uh
so over time uh over the first year of
these on the market I say they get down
down to under 30. so you have something
that's under 30 basis points a year
and it only charges one basis point to
trade
it's going to actually I think produce a
lot of cost pressure on the crypto
exchanges and it will steal some
business so I but that's okay this is a
capitalist Market it's competition but
ETFs have a habit of peeling away
customers from other places be it
individual stock Traders mutual funds
derivatives they're a very compelling
value proposition so that's why this is
such a big deal this is almost like an
alternative to using an exchange
talk a little bit as to what you all
believe would happen when it does get
approved right we've seen some of these
other Bitcoin related ETFs go out I
think they were some of the fastest
growing uh to a billion dollars in
assets
um we've obviously seen gbtc at one
point I think was like 40 50 60 billion
dollars worth of worth of assets you
know some huge kind of uh uh tens of
billions of dollars
is the thought process like BlackRock
launches this thing and it goes to 100
billion in assets and everyone's like
duh of course that was going to happen
or is it something where we've seen
other ETFs uh that have gotten launched
in maybe other jurisdictions and you
know they've kind of floundered a little
bit they've gotten maybe tens of
millions hundreds of millions of dollars
but they haven't really broken through
like gbtc what do you all think would
happen here
yeah so one thing I would say is that
like first mover Advantage here is
definitely critical so like when we saw
the first spot Bitcoin ETF launch in
Canada it beat the others by one day and
it is by far by Far and Away blew away
his competitors and it still does in
volume some others have caught up in
assets but the volume and trading
metrics on the the btcc I think is the
purpose trust in in Canada uh purpose
ETF it blows it away right and then we
also saw the same thing with bito which
is the Bitcoin Futures ETF that you were
referencing it launched first from pro
shares and it blew everything else away
despite others launching right after
which is why Eric was talking about
we're going to see a ton of other people
file immediately on the back of this
like so grayscale a few weeks ago May
9th filed for three ETFs one of them was
uh
it would invest in international spot
Bitcoin ETFs and other things which we
can talk about if you want but the other
one of the main ones was an ethereum
Futures ETF and literally the next day
in a 13-minute window right after the
market closed we saw three issuers file
for an ethereum Futures ETF because they
don't want to be late if they're going
to be late we want to keep it at only a
day because they don't want to lose that
first move of energy they want to be
competitive so that's why we think a lot
of people are are going to file to to
get into this to get into this race and
get one out and the other thing I do
want to point out is there's only one
active spot Bitcoin ETF filing and
that's from 21 shares in partnership
with Arc investment so that's the only
ETF spot Bitcoin ETF that has been filed
right now so
um that that technically would be in
front of line of of BlackRock and then
you also have the situation with
grayscale and suing the SEC but the
traditional 19b4 process for approving
spot Bitcoin ETF only one issuer right
now is active and that's 21 shares in
Arc and and now BlackRock when they file
their 19 before filing which typically
comes a week or two after the the
prospectus that we saw uh we'll we'll
get more information there too oh let me
add to that real quick this is important
point because let's say that I don't
know vanak bit wise let's say one of
these was out first
um I don't know how much assets it would
get right off the bat because Bitcoin
has come back this year and the crypto
miners stocks have come back but no
one's kind of bought back into that in
terms of the ETFs there hasn't been
there's been a lack of fomo like there
was a few years ago and if you look at
the Canadian Bitcoin ETFs they haven't
really taken any money this year I think
there's a little fatigue from after what
happened with FTX and the downturn I
think the local hardcore people are
still owning their Bitcoin but I think
the ETF people who you might call more
touristy they're not biting this time
around that said if Bitcoin continues to
hang around like it normally does goes
up has a nice run and you have a
BlackRock label
this is important because we just wrote
a note comparing BlackRock and Vanguard
ETFs to the IBM stock in the 80s for a
broker it used to be you could never get
fired for for buying IBM for your client
like it's just an unfirable way to
invest
now I think you buy BlackRock or
Vanguard ETFs it's just hard for your
client to have a problem with you and so
the advisor Community is going to feel
much more comfortable having with that
ishares label on it it's huge I can't
understate
how important that is for a lot of
advisors who fear career risk so a
BlackRock one is in a different League
than just a spot one I think that
actually elevates it and I think uh and
I shares one would even move the needle
to creating some fomo uh whereas if a I
don't know a vanic or a like I said one
of the smaller issuers launched a spot
today I'm not sure it would crush it
right off the bat I think because of
this lack of fomo would take a while I
think BlackRock has more of an immediate
effect and for those that are I don't
know did James you agree with that no I
I agree with that I would disagree with
any of it I do think though like there's
been a lack of fomo but I think the
crypto crowd specifically seeing
um a Bitcoin ETF launch in the U.S that
would be a very big deal like it's not
like any other Market where the largest
market by far so I think there might be
some biting but I don't you're right I
don't think it would be the same like we
saw with ditto which was in the
literally that was at the peak of the
Bitcoin and crypto rally in 2021 so that
coincided with with the rally and part
of the reason why I saw so much money
come in
when you all uh think about this
approval process there's going to be a
lot of people who don't understand kind
of this line that you're talking about
is it literally like kind of one in one
out hey the first person in line they
get approved first second person line
they get approved second and if uh I put
my application in and then you put one
in the next day there's a one day delay
in terms of the approval process like
how does this work in terms of this line
and um how much of a Advantage does Arc
uh or others have uh even over the black
rocks given kind of this line
yeah so
um essentially yeah you file first you
get to launch first for the most part so
there's two ways to file the Futures
ETFs go under the 1940 act and like they
have a different process and typically
after file I believe it's just 75 days
Eric can correct me if I'm wrong but the
way that these have to go is an older
School way that uh has oh has been
around for a very long time it's called
the 19b4 process and this is where it
comes about you you've probably seen a
bunch of like articles and things where
it says oh the the SEC has delayed uh
their decision on like spot Bitcoin ETFs
right so basically the way it is you
file 45 days and the SEC has to prove
Deni or delay and it goes 45 days 45
days 90 days 60 days and at the end of
those that that final 60-day period they
either have to prove a deny they can't
delay anymore so like it's that 240-day
period so it's basically it is a
timeline right because once you file
that 19 before application which we're
expecting BlackRock to do very soon like
I said there's literally a ticking clock
of when the SEC needs to reply now
theoretically
if grayscale wins their lawsuit or
there's something going the SEC where
they've basically decided we're not
going to fight Bitcoin anymore I mean I
then theoretically it could be after
that 45-day period that they approve I
would argue that's unlikely because
they've waited 240 days and denied
everything so far
um but like they could do at any time in
those periods that 45 days and then 90
days after that and 45 days after that
things like that they can they can
theoretically approve it
um so um but yes there's literally a
timeline theoretically the SEC can move
things up um they've denied earlier than
the final decision date so they have to
make a decision and officially delay or
approve or deny over that time period
um but yeah it's it's literally just
like waiting in a conga line which we've
written in the past we disagree with
like if you're going to approve a spot
Bitcoin ETF just let a whole bunch at
once like a race like just giving
someone a first move or manage is
literally like a multi-hundred million
dollar benefit potentially over the long
run and the other thing I do want to
point out is
I I mentioned how Futures are filed on
the 40 act there is one ETF that's under
the 1933 act which is what the spot
Bitcoin ETFs would launch under it's
from uh hashtags which is another crypto
company they're based out of Brazil for
the most part but they have a Futures
ETF in the U.S and because it's a 33 act
product the the possibility that if a
Futures ETF I mean a spot Bitcoin ETF
gets approved I think in their language
of their document and the way that
they're structured they could
theoretically immediately start
investing in Bitcoin so while it
wouldn't be the first to get approved
and be a full-blown Futures I mean spot
Bitcoin ETF the ticker from the the ETF
from hashtags which is ticker defy I
think has the potential to be the first
ETF in the U.S holding spot Bitcoin
because as soon as that approval comes
out theoretically they can submit a
change to prospectus and then start
investing in spot Bitcoin but that's
just a pet theory of mine yeah this is
fascinating um before I let you guys go
I need predictions uh does it get
approved or does it not and uh if it
gets approved what is is the 24-hour
capital inflow
you can go first Eric I feel like you're
much better at it I guess good question
um so I've already bet a steak dinner
with Todd Rosenberg it will get approved
now my record with him is three and two
so do that what you will uh I'm not
betting on the SEC changing I'm just
betting on BlackRock knowing something
that's what I'm betting on I'm betting
on BlackRock is not a firm that plays
around and they are they have a lot of
intelligence knowledge
and I just they don't want to get
rejected I mean that's just not what
they do like I said I've just tweeted
out their record of getting ETF filings
approved is 575 and one
it's a pretty good record so I'm going
to bet on that record and bet on
BlackRock and I think they'll be
approval by the end of the year
um what was that record you said it's
570 and one they've had yeah they've had
575 ETFs approved and only one rejected
and why did they have that one rejected
do we know it was an active
non-transparent structure and at the
time the SEC was still wrestling with
these this new structure that would hide
the Holdings and they weren't quite
ready for it
um but they exist now
they do exist now so it wasn't but at
the time they did they did get rejected
on that so like I said it's possible if
I had to give you a percentage I'd
probably go 50 50. but I decided to take
the bet with Todd just because I like
having dinner with him anyway and I like
to see him squirm if there's news I like
to troll him and so we'll have a good
time over the next six months but I'd
say 50 50. um I think BlackRock just
changes so many dynamics of this I was
stunned shocked I still am and this will
be this has sort of taken over my brain
um I had so many other things going on
I'm actually going on vacation next week
too but this is a huge deal
um so that's where and the amount of
money would take in
I don't see it breaking gld's record of
a billion uh in three days well it's
bitters record biddo did it in two days
that's right better dip by the way bitto
is tracks the Futures it actually tracks
spot really well like people were all
worried the Futures wouldn't like do a
good job but I gotta be honest it's very
good like if you want Bitcoin exposure
and ETF bitter is pretty it's fine uh I
I get it though people like the physical
thing they want the stuff stored they
want to know where it is and they went
into track perfectly but bitto is
underrated I thought I thought it did a
fine job over the past two years or so
doing it
um yeah I'd say maybe like it would get
I'd say maybe in the first day a couple
hundred million and then like a billion
by the end of the week and then maybe
like 10 billion by in like six months or
so something like that would make sense
to me
just because there is going to be a
bunch of unmet demand of people who are
just waiting for an ETS they'll move
over quickly we'll call those like
already waiting people the question is
beyond that how much organic interest is
there
um it might not be as much as there was
two three years ago when we predicted
this would be such a big deal simply
because in the meantime we've had a bear
market and FTX
James
yeah so I also think it's going to be
approved
um so that I talked about those 240 days
depending on when BlackRock submits
their 19v4 applications the earliest it
probably could happen is sometime in
late February probably very late
February early March where it would be
the ultimate end deadline
um but I do think it's I I think it's
going to be approved I can't BlackRock I
can't think of any other issuer that if
they filed that it would change my uh my
thesis on whether or not we're gonna get
a spot Bitcoin ETF uh BlackRock is like
as strong as it gets for an indicator on
where the SEC is leaning the other thing
I'm going to say is obviously kind of
unrelated the ETF side of things
coinbase is being sued by the SEC for
operating unlicensed Securities Exchange
all of these things right but one thing
that's not up for question here is
Bitcoin and I kind of wonder if Gary and
the SEC are like we already said that
Bitcoin is not a security we know it's a
commodity we're not even arguing that
while they're arguing ether which I
think is also ridiculous but that's a
different story they might just be like
we'll just let this ETF the Bitcoin ETF
thing go because we need to go after all
these other situations with uh these
other level ones like Solana and uh what
have you like so they're going after
coinbase for those other things and
they're not really worried about Bitcoin
so I wouldn't be surprised if there
might be some changing of their of the
tune within the SEC because I I really
don't understand the reasoning behind
like continuing to not deny these things
um so yeah and then as far as money goes
um I don't know if it would break the
ditto's record of a billion in two days
I don't think it would potentially but I
mean it's not a crazy thing to think I I
this thing will get billions of dollars
um within the first six months I would
guess assuming Bitcoin doesn't half in
price again but uh that's a that's a
different situation
I'm I'm going to uh join you guys and as
we know predictions are stupid and we're
never right but I think yeah I think it
gets a billion dollars in the first day
I I think it's just uh given my very
limited knowledge of the ETF world if
you said to me like what is the thing
that could do it in 24 hours it kind of
feels like it's got to be something that
isn't traditional asset right so you get
Bitcoin it's got to be with a large
issuer like a BlackRock and then it's
got to be something that uh people are
uh talking about in the media and you
need that media attention and you know
just given yesterday just the uh
prospectus alone uh everyone is yelling
and screaming about it on the internet
and
um it just feels like if something was
going to do it why not this yeah I tend
to agree especially if Bitcoin is going
on a run or in a bull market
um like we saw in late 2021 I think that
disability in 24 hours is easily doable
um but obviously in the current
environment right now with how people
look at crypto and the way flows are
going into ETFs like this I would say
it's kind of unlikely but again the
earliest this thing would get approved
is likely in like 45 days the absolute
earliest from what it files the 19
before I believe so
um you're you're likely waiting longer
than that so there's plenty of time
period between now and the beginning of
2024 uh that things could change in in
the underlying Bitcoin Market
also a billion dollars isn't like when
GLD did it that was in 2004 when a
billion dollars was like a billion
dollars like it's a little less
impressive so yeah I I hear you a
billion dollars wouldn't wouldn't
surprise me at all um let's just say
this
it's going to be a big liquid low cost
to trade and likely over time low-cost
area
um ETFs are
one of the most disruptive forces out
there so if I'm in the crypto world and
I see this especially if I work in
exchange I am starting to think of plans
to compete with the ETF
Eric James you guys are the ETF experts
whenever something with an ETF happens
there's only two people in the world
that I say hey what the hell is going on
I appreciate both of you jumping on so
quickly and talking through this uh it's
gonna be fascinating to watch and uh I
think part of what has everyone
intellectually curious about it is not
just the fund structure and kind of
grayscale but also there's the
regulatory kind of environment then you
get this game
um you know between the exchanges and
the ETFs and kind of where's Wall Street
going to actually enter into the market
uh the macro investors I think it's one
of the really interesting things if we
could go back and we had the spot
Bitcoin ETFs in the market where they've
been buying on exchanges or OTC or
they've just been buying the ETF like
there's a lot of implications here that
I think will play out over the next
couple of months so I appreciate you
guys and I'll definitely have you back
as some of that develops
yeah anytime always fun chatting with
you where can we send people to find all
your great work
um I would say our Twitter is where you
get a lot of our quick takes for free we
also have a podcast called trillions and
we have there's a TV show ETF IQ on
Bloomberg TV all those are free ways to
get us if you have a terminal Bloomberg
terminal you can find us on BI ETF go
James watch this hey Eric you want to
hold up your book one more time just for
the people's sake sure actually should
hold up both books look at that yeah
there you go this is the whole this is
great for ETF knowledge this is great
for how every how we got here the whole
passing thing so anyway please
amazon.com
all right guys thank you very much we'll
talk soon bye